Read text around you with Seeing AI
The first Seeing AI channel is short text.
And like the name suggests, we can use this
for reading text in our environment.
You’d be surprised just how many things
have writing on.
And Seeing AI can instantly read any, not
handwriting, but any standard text.
The ability for computers to read text using
OCR has been around for many years.
But what makes this unique is the way that
it starts reading straight away.
A simple example hear.
I have two envelopes for me and a colleague.
But I don’t know which is mine.
So I’m just going to take one of these envelopes
and put it under the camera.
> Anirudh Koul
Cool.
So as you heard, it said Anirudh Koul, who
is my colleague.
So that’s not my envelope.
So, just to make sure, let’s try the other
envelope.
> Saqib Shaikh.
Cool.
Bad pronunciation, but yes, that’s, that’s
mine.
Now that worked quite well.
Sometimes, however, you may find that the
app doesn’t read all the text.
That might be, because you’re off to the
side or a bit too close.
So you should try moving the phone around
until you get all the texting in view.
Also, this works best for short amounts of
answer text, where it can all be in view at
once.
If you want to read a whole document, then
we have a different channel for that.
And talking of documents, I wonder what’s
inside the envelope.
Microsoft logo appears.